LYNN LANGIT: Hi, I'm Lynn
Langit, cloud architect
and developer and the first
Google Developer Expert,
or GDE.
Lately, I've been working
with bioinformatics clients
building cloud-based
genomic-scale pipelines.
In this talk, I'm going
to talk about patterns
for implementing effective
pipelines on the Google Cloud
Platform.
There are four
parts, what is needed
in this area, why do we
need to have patterns
and how do you
learn them, how are
you going to use
pattern information,
and how can you learn more.
First we need to understand the
scale and scope of the problem.
In my work as a
cloud architect, I've
worked with some
pretty big data sets
in fintech in New York and
London, in adtech in LA,
but genomic-scale data
sets are a whole new level.
The amount of data
that's being generated
by mostly human genomic
analysis requires new patterns
for building effective analysis
pipelines in the cloud.
Now, when I talk about
scale, what do I mean?
Can I give an example?
Yeah, I will.
A recent client that
I've been working with
is the Broad Institute
at MIT and Harvard.
On average, they've been
putting in 17 terabytes per day
into the Google Cloud.
This is an astounding number.
Think about it in your own
work in data pipelining.
Are any of you
working at anywhere
close to the scale yet?
If not, I think you will be,
even if you're not in genomics.
And the reason for
this is the amount
of data that's being generated.
I've had other projects
in the IoT area in adtech,
and they come close to this.
But genomics is at
the cutting edge.
So what are the challenges
in building effective GCP
pipelines at this scale?
Well, there is a lot of them.
First, cloud practices--
which services
should our researchers use?
Should they use
virtual machines?
Should they use BigQuery?
Should they use
higher level services?
How are they going to
understand DevOps practices?
How are they going to work
with configuration as code?
And really importantly,
how are they
going to learn about
service cost control?
You can make a very
expensive mistake very fast
with this amount of data.
Speaking of data,
how are we going
to try out and learn
these services?
The data that many of
my clients work with
is personally identifiable
human health data.
How are we going to work
with downsampled data sets?
These data sets are huge.
They have 3 billion letters.
And they do analysis
across the genome.
Speaking of the genome,
researchers really
want to work with
genomics examples.
Most of the examples in
Learning Cloud Services
are generic, hello world.
And that really doesn't
resonate my customers.
On top of that,
in genomics, there
is an increasing approach moving
towards tools and libraries
such as GATK, the
Genomic Analysis Tool
Kit, and the "widdle," or WDL,
Workflow Definition Language,
the next Nextflow
library and language, NF,
and Galaxy Project.
There are many others.
So what I've done to address
this knowledge gap is,
I've created an open-source
course on GitHub.
It is 100% free,
because it's on GitHub.
And it consists of notes marked
on pages, screencasts, code
examples, and sample data.
Importantly, all of the
examples use genomic data.
It's called GCP
for Bioinformatics.
So this course
introduces researchers
to working with raw Google
Cloud infrastructure
or systems for genomic analysis
built on the Google Cloud,
including Tera.bio from the
Broad Institute in [INAUDIBLE],,
VarianceSpark Library from
CSIRO Bioinformatics in Sydney,
Australia, Nextflow.Io
from the group in Europe,
Galaxy Project, which
is global, and others.
Now, to get an understanding
of the complexity,
let's first consider batch
compute for analysis.
If you start at the
bottom of the diagram,
although today we're talking
about the Google Cloud,
many of my researchers are faced
with the additional complexity
of collaborating with
researchers who work
with a different vendor cloud.
So we have a number of
public vendor clouds.
On top of that, they'll
build their analysis
on clusters of virtual machines,
and increasingly, containers.
And on top of that,
many of them are now
starting to use orchestration
layers, such as Spark
or Kubernetes.
On top of all that
cloud infrastructure,
researchers are often using
these bioinformatics tools
and libraries that I
previously mentioned,
such as Tera.bio,
Nextflow, Galaxy, and more.
Those libraries have
associated languages,
such as "widdle," WDL,
CWL, Common Workflow
Language, Nextflow, NF, or GA.
And those tools often
have orchestration layers,
such as Cromwell for
Tera.bio or MiniWDL.
Pipeline's API is
actually a Google API
that works in
conjunction with a lot
of these higher-level libraries.
Does this look confusing?
Well, it is.
There is a lot of different
tools and libraries
to understand.
It's one of the reasons
that I made this course,
to break all these services
into parts and pieces
so that they can be learned
and understood individually
and then combined effectively.
Now, in addition
to batch compute,
you'll notice a similar but
non-identical kind of pattern
here.
And this is
interactive analysis.
Now, this keys around
the center square,
in the center of the center
square, the iPython Notebook,
or ipymb.
It is becoming a
pattern in genomics
to create reproducible research
in the form of a Jupyter
Notebook.
And so an important
pattern in pipelining
is scaling those
notebook environments
using Jupyter Hub
or Google Colabs.
So again, there are a
number of parts and pieces
to working with these
pipelining infrastructures.
And my course covers all of
these on the Google Cloud.
So drilling into the highlights
of what my course covers,
it really is designed to
be consumed in the way
that you actually
work with the cloud.
There is a level zero for
setting up your account
and setting up cost control.
Level one is files and
data, because, of course,
we're computing on files.
And I cover core services,
such as storage buckets, Google
Cloud Storage.
I cover public data
sets that are available,
such as 1,000 Genomes
and other data
sets for genomics
that have restricted
access, services
like BigQuery, which
provides serverless SQL
querying on top of files
and can be used for genomic type
files, such as VCF, or Variant
Calling Format.
Also, I cover higher level
services, such as Tera.bio
reference data sets.
In the compute
area, I cover topics
such as virtual machines,
running containers,
and of course, clusters
of each of these,
and also include information
about serverless or functions
at the workflow level,
but also the Google life
sciences, API which is called
the Pipelines API, Nextflow,
and higher level services
such as Tera.bio.
Additionally, to cover
the interactive pattern,
I have information about
working with and setting up
Jupyter Notebook environments
on the Google Cloud platform.
I also include modern DevOps
practices such as CI/CD,
or Continuous Integration
and Continuous Deployment.
And I have information
about machine learning
that's specific to
genomics, covering examples
of libraries like Deep Variant,
TensorFlow IO, and Google
Nucleus.
Another aspect of
the course design
is that my examples are
designed to be quick.
One of the challenges
that I found
when I was learning genomics
tools as a cloud architect is
many of the examples
reflected real world.
And real world can be
huge amounts of data.
So a hello world can take
minutes, or hours, or even
days to run.
And that just wasn't a
way that I wanted to work.
So I provide example data.
And I provide specific steps
to try out each service.
My course is designed to run on
a trial Google Cloud Platform
account.
And if you run with
my example data sets,
it should be a nearly no cost.
I never pay more than $1 or $2.
And importantly, most examples
run in five minutes or less.
So you can quickly
get up and running.
And you can find
out if the service
is going to work for your
particular analysis needs.
Another aspect to the way I've
designed the course is I've
designed it at three levels
for each of the service areas,
so for example, for files,
for data, for compute,
so on and so forth.
So the three levels are
infrastructure as a service.
And this is for researchers
who want to set up, control,
and manage everything.
The level of data,
for example, they
might want to set up their own
RDBMS, or relational database.
They might want to set up
their own NoSQL environment
on virtual machines or on
Google Cloud Storage buckets.
At the compute layer,
these researchers
would prefer to set up their
own clusters of Google Compute
Engine virtual machines
or Docker images on Google
Kubernetes Engine.
There are other researchers
who would prefer
to work at the platform level.
They would rather run their
analysis over managed services
and let Google handle more of
the underlying infrastructure.
So data, this looks
like data lakes
that are running on GCS
buckets, Google Cloud Storage
buckets, and use of public
reference genomics data.
At the compute layer,
this often manifests
by using services such as
Dataproc or the Google Life
Sciences API, which efficiently
handles orchestration of groups
of virtual machines, allowing
the researchers to dynamically
spin up and spin down
compute resources.
And it allows them
to take advantage
of aspects that are
specific to Google Cloud,
such as preemptable
instances, so that they
can save lots of money, which is
really important at this scale.
Still, other researchers
prefer to work at the software
as a service level.
And one example of this is
using the Tera.bio system,
which is a web UI
that was designed
by the Broad institute in
[INAUDIBLE] that currently runs
on top of the Google
Cloud Platform.
In this case, rather than
interacting with the GCP
console or using
tools such as gsutil,
my researchers will go
to the Tera.bio platform.
And they can access
both their own data
and publicly available genomic
data through the Tera UI.
Also they can spin up and spin
down Jupyter Notebook instances
and compute clusters that run
on top of the Life Sciences API
through the web UI.
Now, that's a lot of different
areas to think about.
So I think at this
point, it will be helpful
if we actually take just a brief
look at the course on GitHub.
In this demo, I want to show
you my open-source course that I
built, GCP for Bioinformatics.
So first, we're going to go
out to the site on GitHub.
And this is where all the
artifacts for the course
are located.
You can see that the course
is organized by topic area.
And it's set up in folders.
So they're numbered
in a logical order.
You would, of course, start by
setting up your GCP account.
Then you would work
with files of data.
Then you would work with virtual
machines, Docker containers,
or functions, so compute,
and multiple instances.
You may add machine learning.
You also might use
code and cloud service
tools, such as
continuous integration
and continuous deployment,
container registries,
and other tools.
In each section,
the organization
is set up as follows.
At the beginning of each
section, there is a read me.
So there is a main read me.
I'll just scroll down here.
And you can see that
I've consistently
used Emoji throughout
the repository
to make it easier to scan.
You can see the list here.
As it says, this repo
includes content you
can read, watch, or run.
So you can read
pages of the repo.
You can think of them as notes.
You can watch linked
YouTube screencasts.
They're demonstrations.
You can try out the
computational examples
using Jupyter Notebooks.
There are linked GitHub repos.
And there are additional
advanced topic links
at the end of each section.
On each page, there will
be a linked YouTube video.
So you just click the
graphic to go to the video.
If you prefer to learn
by watching screencasts,
you can simply go
to the playlists
that I've created and linked.
And as you can see, there are
27 different short screencasts,
mostly around five minutes--
some of them are six or seven--
that cover the topics
via demonstrations.
Now, just to get an idea of
how each topic is set up,
we'll take a look
at one topic area
just so you can understand
the structure, which
is consistent
throughout the course.
So here we have in the
files and data section--
in that section, we have a
topic called SQL questions.
And this topic is covering
using the BigQuery service
with a bioinformatics
or genomic example.
So you can see, first, there is
a little explanation about it.
And then these
notes pages are very
action-oriented in the
design, in that they're
created so that you
can actually try out
the service with a genomics
example within 5 to 10 minutes,
and get a result
that quickly as well.
So this is a little bit unusual.
And that's one of the
reasons I made the course,
because I've seen a lot
of bioinformatics examples
that take hours to run.
And I really, in
course design, wanted
to create examples that
would cost basically nothing
to try out because of the tiny
sizes of the sample data sets
and would be just
really quick and easy.
Now, in the case
of BigQuery, I've
included a number of
screenshots in this notes page,
because I'm assuming that, for
most people taking the course,
this will be a new service.
So you can see, for example,
I've used this screenshot
in the beginning of this page.
Now, this page
actually is a link out
to an additional course.
And this is a course
on using the ANSI SQL
language against a
sample genomic data set.
And if you just
go down the page,
this page is a little bit longer
than some of the other pages,
because it's a
three-part course.
And you can see, for example,
we've got SQL queries here
that you can actually run.
Now, just to show you how
this is intended to be used,
the course is designed to
be used with a trial GCP
actual account so you can run
the lessons and learn by doing.
So for this particular
one, if I scroll
way down here for a second--
and I'll just stop here.
This is an example using a
concept called a self-join
on a very, very small, but
a domain-specific example.
And so the idea here is
to return a hierarchy.
And the lesson,
as you can see, is
write a SQL query to return
the grandparent category
of glycine binding.
So to show you the environment
where you'd work with this,
this is BigQuery in GCP.
And for this course, I've
created a publicly available
really small sample data set.
So you can see here, I'll click
on this experiments table.
And I can actually preview it.
And it has just
five rows, again,
really tiny examples here.
One of the concepts,
as I've mentioned,
in talking about this
course is that you
can explore these services
with examples that come
from genomics that are tiny.
So they can do it
basically at no cost
and in just a short
amount of time.
So the course is
completely on GitHub.
So it's completely free.
It's completely open source.
I really welcome any
suggestions from the community.
The best way to do that is
through a poll request, sort
of the typical GitHub process.
And I really look forward
to the contributions
and the feedback of the
bioinformatics research
community.
It's Lynn Langit.
And this course is GCP
for Bioinformatics.
Thank you.